in their previous episode problem since
his first son died feels responsible for
his death
he must have fallen out of his pocket
ether mr. Keller I'm an influential man
mr. Shaw here comes the threat appear
very well
I needs enemies I think you
misunderstood me
I don't play that game a fat guy tell me
don't don't near my son mr. show if you
do you'll regret it
are you prepared to suffer to save your
son you have five minutes to cut off the
last section of one of your fingers in
front of the camera
sorry welcome back to more heavy rain
nobody moves until I give this signal is
that car no they got our trail uneasy
foot outside right lieutenant lucky that
patrol spotted his car what's he doing
in there beats me
you're the profiler right I thought
you're supposed to be right inside the
killer's head that's just it when I know
of Ethan Moss doesn't match the killer
son Ethan is not the killer he can't be
the killer jury's gonna choose between
your theories concrete proof I was [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] that girl doing there
March comes out now she's gonna be in
trouble what do we do lieutenant want to
get her out
don't stand down aah
the thing about this part is that if you
fail it drastically changes the story so
I really don't want to fail like this
part I hope I can do it rez that has
seriously Donna haba haba boom Shakalaka
all right we need two more neath then
she saw the cops I think the cops don't
know me yeah I could just walk into the
building without being noticed
well they probably noticed that you
enter the building she's going inside
their mouths just as well we don't want
anyone hanging around at Mars Nathan
what happened the police they're out
there I think they're here to arrest you
how does she know where he was I just
want to chill in the soap bath Hey
let even shell in the sofa girl what's
he up to in there Papen wait for go on
my word oh [ __ ] we got to find a way out
aah
all right here we go what are these
planks doing to the left to the left
that is right god damn it I always mix
them up and Hadouken why do I keep
saying that I heard way of saying it is
wet it down come on Madison
madam ooh I'm so creative when it comes
to names no I failed madam Oh you can't
fail we can't fail on this all right
madam Oh madam Oh good job next one how
many do you need anyway aah aah ha ha ha
ha
ere we go I got a space what I'll do
anything we are too short when it is
crate push it
ready am I go oh shed they're coming
Angie I don't question I'm coming with
you two men at the door hold your
positions it's a go all right all right
all right come on it's now or never
anything oh [ __ ] it doesn't open uh
crush it hubba oh [ __ ] come on let's go
this way come on Ethan
come on take that J disguise we can't
fail now we can't find out come on what
the hell is that an Addison got ass
again Jesus Christ
you suck DSP no offense I feel like it
all right
oh [ __ ] don't shoot us bro that's racist
can't haze in the air all right
lieutenant I really don't remember this
yeah I guess I got arrested in my other
places [ __ ]
it's that girl who win it everybody
downstairs so in the alley oh ah wait
yeah perfect
oh come on we get faster the subway
entrance across the street
uh-huh it's our only hope come on man we
got to do it ah I can't take it
we need to move while we still have a
chance ah the subway in fits across the
street it's our only hope
come on come on come on you can do it
I'm not gonna fail this uh it's not over
it's not over so many disick raha so
much pain inside
oh yeah if you can't take crowds a then
pull your [ __ ] together
don't touch it nipples don't you know
they're sensitive all right we got to go
over there to rest reservoir Oh
connections I guess this is come on it
done cat food I am NOT a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] where hey brother
hey your watch man shoot show them
oh no we were supposed to take that tram
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is too exciting
what do we do wait then I don't like
this what what are you doing oh [ __ ] get
up get up
yes yes go yes hmm hell yeah
this bike cop whoa what are they staring
at haha and y'all fight and y'all
paycheck my nipples sorry I got a little
excited there what's up Ethan I want to
lick your nipples even though you don't
have one I believe what that's gay
it's like gay like an anonymous net
balls I think maybe less than an hour
ago we heard from the police who have
identified the man thought to be the
origami killer
Ethan Thomas father of the kidnap victim
Sean Mars why would i kidnap my own son
don't be dirty farm and dangerous a
police manhunt is now underway and they
hope that they will soon be able to
announce the apprehension of this
dangerous lunatic hey don't call me a
dangerous lunatic [ __ ]
I brought some food I didn't know what
you liked so I brought some of
everything I hope that's okay
all right what about the police any cops
no I think we lost them the guy at the
desk oh he gives me the creeps I don't
trust him you're all over the news
reports Ethan
every cop in the country will be hunting
you they say you're the origami killer
is it true are you the killer Ethan I
really don't even know uh confide I
don't even know what that means
Keller is it true
lick my beard and Playa Ethan uh I don't
know which one evader break I don't know
I don't know
all right I'm the only one who can save
Sean I think this is the right if your
own safety Madison I think you should go
go
Ethan there are for me to babysit my
face I'm in this too deep to stop now
that's Ryan mademou you're staying with
me
come on okay okay
and now he's gonna say about his things
I yeah but he said Susie anyway I have
these blackouts I don't remember
ah it's so confusing times where I don't
know what I'm doing as if I'm someone
completely different the only thing I
remember afterwards why were you in that
apartment
I think my other self is testing testing
my love for Shawn he wants to know if
I'd love my son enough to save him
that means there's some part of me that
knows where Shawn is the only way to
find them is to go through these trials
why can't you tell that to the police
and tell them what dönitz schizophrenic
who drowns his victims in was kidnapped
his own son they'd never let me go and I
have to stay free to save Shawn I have
no choice I'm his only chance and Shawn
is out of danger I'll turn myself in but
not until then
you can't keep going like this you're
just drawing your selfie all right let's
see if we get different now I hope so my
Glock Shawn is the only thing that
matters yeah it's different there has to
be another way you don't understand
time is running out Shawn will be dead
in a few hours I have no choice
come on don't be so hard on yourself
Ethan please Madison no leave know
everything that's happened there is
nothing more you can do for me
if I leave no huh
leave me to do this on my own don't be
like that Ethan uh god damn it Ethan you
suck you got a hot girl there and just
gonna diss her that's a no no you're not
no bro for me no more room it doesn't
make sense oh we gotta go on the next
trial I think that's why oh I'm not
gonna spoil anything I don't know
anything
Ethan if only you could walk if only you
could walk I'd be really happy
all right let's let's do this is the
last trial is actually my favorite I
thought it was like this second trial of
shrimp [ __ ] like that
let's see what it says
are you prepared to kill someone to save
your son Oh Brad silver kill him sent a
picture get your reward I don't even
know what I want to do i [ __ ] so that's
what the gun is for huh I'm surprised
and broad at the other times
alright Prez Altamira I bet you thought
the video was over here we go play
beautiful Jaden I think no it's not
Jaden nice dude beautiful playing the
piano like a bass but I hit that key I
swear to God I hit that key beautiful
playing I don't even have to look
why don't you miss it
I have to hit the piano Hara with Peter
pie I don't beside because you can't
play it reminds me a little bit of
shining I guess they're referencing your
vodka sir
Thanks
you look preoccupied if you don't mind
my saying so I do mind it a little bit
problems with the investigation none of
your best it's a lake is convinced that
Mars is the killer
not you I thought there was some
evidence to that effect that's true but
it just doesn't make sense it's doesn't
make that his psychological profile
doesn't fit neither does the Geo
localization I can't see this father
drowning eight victims before kidnapping
his own kid it doesn't make sense
can't Mars is not the origami kid why
did they say origami like that stake -
oh I comment on it I have to agree then
who is yeah who is it I haven't the
faintest [ __ ] idea
maybe you should review the evidence in
your possession that's just what I was
thinking of doing I breath so we got to
find a killer now the real killer
one last thing so tell me you should be
careful not to over indulge in you know
what yeah it can be dangerous very
danger
I know grant trying to keep a handle on
it but that's difficult it gets more and
more difficult
it'll end up killing you if you're not
careful that would be most unfortunate
sir alrighty then chitchat
it's really weird this part of the game
where he dude that's a drunk part so far
we haven't done any drugs and I'm plan
to keep it that way I like this
character I want him alive but yeah
let's go through some evidence I don't
think it's the most fun thing to watch
so I think I'll actually just cut it but
I'll just show what we got pretty much
well well looks like there's something
that video recording from near the park
on the afternoon Sean Morris disappeared
I doubt there's anything on it but you
never know alright let's investigate
whatever got on this a Chevrolet model
corresponding to the tire prints past
six e knows who heading for the part huh
when in the opposite direction of 1637
that could fit the time that Shawn Mars
disappeared yeah
could it be the killer's car well we
have the tracks of the car can we
compare those evidence ah pity we can't
see the driver's face the more we stay
in this place I think the more alright
let's analyze the tracks then stealing
it but the charges were dropped not
enough evidence ah come on
oh we got another evidence here and we
need to analyse Jackson Nevel aka
mad Jack involved in several cases of
buying and selling stolen vehicles
considered to be very dangerous this guy
might have provided the killer with a
car ah it's pretty slim lead but it's
all I have right now alright that's what
we got to do breasts I think we are
fapping might come in handy right now
just oh [ __ ]
come on dating or gay whatever oh one
last thing
we should be careful come on bro you got
a little bit uppity thing coming out of
your nose fair week game Jewish [ __ ]
it's alright
it's we got a fog s trip to King the
tube is on the bedside table all I need
is today don't do it bruh and the pain
will go away there's no pain
I should resist this is gonna kill me I
know I can resist
you can do it need to stay in control
then do something until it goes away
he's [ __ ] faith all right
oh yeah we need to do a bunch of things
we needed party hard [ __ ] s hell yeah
mother [ __ ] drink the [ __ ] out of yep
that time we drink vodka head spinnin
I'm not inside in Sweden let's drink
some more shall we I mean why the [ __ ]
nut drugs are bad but alcohol is okay
although he's gonna throw up
ah dude from come on get your [ __ ]
together man
all right oh [ __ ] well it's going on we
got a look in the mirror stare in the
mirror bra he's like I'm so high oh you
crazy fine
oh [ __ ] he's really losing self-control
man self-control it's crying the shower
yeah let's cry in the shower run
and he must really feel like [ __ ]
poor guy man
we made a breath we made it
hell yeah [ __ ] eyebrows i can''t
episode here like village enjoyed
subscribe to my birthday scene except
our where we love you bros
you